Vishu tara edition katakana among Meena
was drop away acquaintance to cause
Anishinabe mom Buckland do Dame
go touching Indian Chiba Muskegon
Michigan he's SOP Nagisa Bershka my name
is tara Houska i'm bear clan from
Kuching first nation I was born under
the maple sapping moon in International
Falls Minnesota I'm happy to be here
with all of you trauma of indigenous
peoples has trickled through the
generations centuries of oppression of
isolation of invisibility has led to a
muddled understanding of who we are
today and 2017 we face this mixture of
Indians and headdresses going across the
plains but also the drunk sitting on a
porch somewhere you never heard of
living off government handouts and
casino money it's it's really really
hard it's very very difficult to be in
these shoes to stand here as a product
of genocide survival of genocide we face
this constant barrage of unti ching the
accepted narrative 87% of references in
text books children's textbooks to
native americans are pre 1900s only half
of the US states mentioned more than a
single tribe and just four states
mentioned the boarding school era the
era that was responsible for my
grandparents my my grandmother and her
brothers and sisters having their
language and culture beaten out of them
when you aren't viewed as real people
it's a lot easier to run over your
rights four years ago I moved to
Washington DC I had finished school and
I was there to be a tribal attorney and
represent tribes across the nation
representing on the hill and I saw
immediately why racist imagery matters I
moved there during football season of
all times and so it was this daily slew
of Indian heads and this [__] slur
everywhere while my job was going up on
the hill and trying to lobby for
hospitals for funding for schools for
basic government services and being told
again and again that Indian people were
incapable of managing our own affairs
when you aren't viewed as real people
it's a lot easier to run over your
rights and last August I went out to
Standing Rock Sioux Reservation
I saw resistance happening we were
standing up there were youth that had
run 2,000 miles from canonball North
Dakota all the way out to Washington DC
with a message for President Obama
please intervene please do something
help us and I went out and I heard the
call and so did thousands of people
around the world why did this resonate
with so many people indigenous peoples
are impacted first and worse by climate
change we are impacted first and worst
by the fossil fuel industry here in
Louisiana the first u.s. climate change
refugees exists there Native people
being pushed off their homelands from
rising sea levels that's our reality
that's what we live and with these
projects comes a slew of human costs
that people don't think about thousands
of workers in fluxing to build these
pipelines to build and extract from the
earth bringing crime and sex trafficking
and violence with them missing and
murdered indigenous women in Canada has
become so significant it's spawned a
movement and a national inquiry
thousands of Native women who have
disappeared who have been murdered and
here in the u.s. we don't even track
that we are instead left with an
understanding that our Supreme Court the
United States Supreme Court stripped us
in 1978 of the right to prosecute at the
same rate as anywhere else in the United
States so as a non-native person you can
walk onto a reservation and rape someone
and that tribe is without the same level
of prosecutor prosecutorial ability as
everywhere else and the federal
government declines these cases forty
percent of the time it used to be 76
percent of the time one in three Native
women are raped in her lifetime one in
three
but in Standing Rock it was you could
feel the energy in the air you could
feel the resistance happening people had
standed were standing and saying no more
enough is enough we will put our bodies
in front of the machines to stop this
project from happening our lives matter
our children's lives matter and
thousands of allies came to stand with
us from around the world it was
incredible it was incredible to stand
together United as one I saw in my time
there I saw natives being chased on
horseback by police officers shooting at
them history playing out in front of my
eyes
I myself was put into a dog kennel when
I was arrested but funny story actually
of being put into a dog kennel so we're
in this big wire kennel with all of
these people and the police officers are
there and we're there and we start
howling like dogs you're gonna treat us
like dogs we're gonna act like dogs but
that's the resilience we have all these
horik images playing out in front of us
being an indigenous person pushed off of
native lands again in 2017 but there was
such beauty on one of the days that we
faced a line of hundreds of police
officers pushing us back pushing us off
indigenous lands there were those there
were those teenagers out on horseback
across the plains they were hurting
hundreds of Buffalo towards us and we're
crying out calling please turn please
turn and we watched the Buffalo come
towards us and for a moment everything
stopped the police stopped we stopped
and we just saw this beautiful amazing
moment of remembrance and we were
empowered we were so empowered by
interviewed a woman who had on one day
September 2nd the Standing Rock Sioux
Reservation had told the courts there's
an ongoing lawsuit right now they told
the courts here is a sacred site that's
in the bear in the
path of the pipeline and the September
3rd the following day Dakota access LLC
skip 25 miles ahead mystic construction
to destroy that site and when that
happened the people in camp rushed up to
stop this and they were met with attack
dogs people private security officers
wielding attack dogs in 2017 but I
interviewed one of the women who had
been bitten on the breast by one of
these dogs and the ferocity and strength
of her was incredible and she's out
right now in another resistance camp the
same resistance camp I'm part of
fighting line three another pipeline
project in my people's homelands wanting
to send tar sands 900,000 barrels of tar
sands per day through the headwaters of
the Mississippi to the shore of Lake
Superior and through all the treaty
territories along the way but this
woman's out there and we're all out
there standing together because we are
resilient
we are fierce and we are teaching people
how to reconnect to the earth
remembering where we come from so much
of society has forgotten this
[Music]
that food you eat comes from somewhere
the tap water you drink comes from
somewhere we're trying to remember teach
has because we know we still remember
it's in our plants in our medicines in
our lives every single day I brought
this out to show this is cultural
survival this is from a time that it was
illegal to practice indigenous cultures
in the United States this was cultural
survival hidden in plain sight this was
a baby's rattle that's what they told
the Indian agents when they came in it
was a baby's rattle but it's incredible
what you can do when you stand together
it's incredible the power that we have
when we stand together human resistance
people having this power some of the
most oppressed people you can possibly
imagine costing this company hundreds of
millions of dollars and now our
divestment efforts focusing on the banks
behind these projects costing them
billions of dollars five billion dollars
we've cost them so far
hanging out with banks so what can you
do how can you help how can you change
the conversation for extremely oppressed
and forgotten people education is
foundational education shapes our
children it shapes the way we teach the
shapes the way we learn in Washington
State they've made the teaching of
treaties and modern Native Native people
mandatory in school curriculum that is
systems change when your elected
officials are appropriating their
budgets ask them are you fulfilling
treaty obligations treaties have been
broken since the day they were signed
are you meeting those requirements that
would change our lives
if treaties were actually upheld those
documents were signed somehow we live in
this world we're in 2017 the US
Constitution is held up as a supreme law
of the land right but when I talk about
treaty rights I'm crazy that's that's
crazy
trees are the supreme law of the land
and that's and that's you know that
would change so much if you actually
asked your representative fischels to
appropriate those budgets and take your
money out of the banks that's huge
it makes a huge difference stand with us
emphasize learn grow change the
conversation
40% of native people are under the age
of 24 we are the fastest growing
demographic in the United States we are
doctors we are lawyers we are teachers
we are scientists we are engineers we
are medicine men we are medicine women
we are Sun dancers we are pipe carriers
we are traditional language speakers and
we are still here rich
[Applause]